[Musik]
ist eine dieser Kleinstädte die wir ein
Gradmesser sind für ganz Serbien eine
etwas verschlafene Gegenwart eine reiche
aber auch tödliche Vergangenheit und ein
Ehrenbürger mit Namen Vladimir Putin
Milos cetanovic hat sogar seine Kneipe
nach ihm benannt
der Krieg ändert an seiner Bewunderung
für den Mann und das Land nichts im
Gegenteil
war ein bisschen
ich glaube dass die Stimmung immer mehr
für Russland ist
und immer weniger für die EU
doch Serbiens Wohlstand kommt vor allem
aus der EU wissen auch seine Gäste das
Land sitzt zwischen den Stühlen
Russland ist meinem Herzen näher die EU
ist unserem Business näher
es ist eine schwierige Frage
im Visier von Ost und West sei Serbien
Titeln die Zeitung die EU will das
Serbien Sanktionen mitmacht russland
will das gerade nicht Treibstoff Energie
Lebensmittel werden teurer auch ohne
dass Serbien Sanktionen verhängt Nadja
staßkunden kommen seltener und greifen
nach billigerer Ware offiziell liegt die
Inflation bei 14 Prozent Nadja Star
meinte sei viel mehr besonders und
Feuerholz
letztes Jahr war das halb so teuer
schade Brennholz können wir uns jetzt
nicht mehr leisten
in schwierigen Zeiten haben klare
Feindbilder zu laufen bei den serbischen
Nationalisten ist es die Nato und auch
die EU
Damian knesevic und seine
volkspatrouille sind eingeladen bei
einer Party für die verlorene Provinz
Kosovo die NATO sehen Sie
mitverantwortlich für den Verlust
[ __ ] [ __ ] NATO packt rufen Sie und Samen
und Russen sind Brüder für immer
Russland stand ihn bei im Kosovo Krieg
Ende der 90er die NATO dagegen
bombardierte Serbien die
Kriegsverbrechen von Serben die das
auslösten lässt knirsevic unerwelt der
Mann der mit seiner volksparteilie schon
mal Migranten bedroht meint es sei
serbische Pflichten und den Russen
beizustehen
Russland ist auf einem guten Weg das ist
auch eine Chance für alle Serben uns
nationale Interessen zu besinnen unser
Leben zu verbessern und das Joch
abzuschütteln das auf uns liegt
das Joch dass die EU angeblich auferlegt
mit ihren Werten von Toleranz und
Gleichberechtigung die der orthodoxen
Kirche und vielen Serben Widerstreben
ein Anti lgbtq-protest in Belgrad geriet
kürzlich so zur pro russland-demo auch
weil knesewitch diese riesige
russisch-serbische Fahne organisierte
eine Mehrheit der Serben ist inzwischen
gegen die EU
das helsinki-komitee beobachtet mit
Sorge das rechtsextreme immer aktiver
werden und Zulauf haben
in Serbien fällt das illiberale
nationalistische narrativ auf
fruchtbaren Boden meint Isabella kisic
a das was groß Russland im Post
sowjetischen Raum tut kann Serbien
helfen das gleiche in seiner Region zu
tun so die Überzeugung der Nationalisten
sie glauben an Russland Sieg
diese Wähler bedient auch Präsident
rucic die Freundschaft mit Russland
fliegt er weiter auch wenn er seit
Kriegsbeginn solche Bilder meidet aber
wutschitsch besteht darauf keine
Sanktionen er will die russlandfreunde
zu Hause nicht verschrecken
doch Serbien ist seit zehn Jahren
eu-kandidat die EU macht nun Druck
zuletzt beim Gipfel in Prag wenn Serbien
im europäischen Gruppenfoto steht Handel
Subventionen will dann muss die
serbische Schaukelpolitik enden so groß
war der Druck auf rucic noch nie
isabella kisic ist froh dass die EU nun
aufgewacht ist die UNO dreschen die
Probleme interne Probleme der westlichen
Gemeinschaft führten dazu dass die EU
sich weniger um Serbien kümmerte
Einfluss
[Musik]
in chinesevic Augen ist die
slawisch-orthodoxe Bruderschaft mit
Russland fast heilig Präsident
wutschisch sei ein Verräter meint er er
habe sich schon zu oft der EU gebeugt
der Weg gen Westen sei für Serbien ein
Disaster
die Richtung in die die EU geht da will
ich Serbien und meine Kinder nicht sehen
dieser Liberalismus ist wirklich zu viel
jeder darf leben wir will aber das was
da jetzt aus Brüssel der EU und Berlin
kommt das ist der pure nazi-liberalismus
jetzt ist nun
öfter angesprochen man kennt ihn in
komplizierten Krisenzeiten suchen
Menschen halt in seinem
illiberalen Weltbild
das ist nicht typisch serbisch das kennt
man auch in anderen Ländern besonders in
Ungarn
Viktor Orban gewann die letzte Wahl mit
vielen nationalem Pathos und Populismus
für seine Sätze über den westlichen
gender waren bekommt er den größten
Applaus
[Applaus]
doch seine Macht Erhalt dienen auch
Wahlrecht und Medien und gute
Beziehungen zu Russland er bremst bei
EU-Sanktionen er will den Eindruck
erwecken ungarnskrise ist keinesfalls
seine Schuld
wir danken den Eltern und Schülern steht
an einer Grundschule in Budapest Dank
für Unterstützung in einem Lehrerstreik
Marian Zeki und ihre Kollegen schafft
hatten die Nase voll seit Jahren sind
sie unter bezahlt und überlastet es
fehlen nicht nur hier Lehrer sondern
Ungarn weit tausende
und jetzt auch noch die Inflation von
ihrem Gehalt bleibt immer weniger übrig
hat auf jeden Fall natürlich spürt man
die Inflation
es ist jetzt alles doppelt so teuer wie
vor zwei Wochen
der Aufschnitt kostete vor zwei Wochen
300 Forint jetzt 600 Forint
sie verdient rund 200.000 Forint brutto
das sind rund 500 Euro seit Jahren
kämpfen die Lehrer um mehr Geld schon
vor dem Krieg begann die Inflation
Marianne zigli genießt die letzten
Sonnenstrahlen denn der Winter wird
schwer und deshalb hat sie gekündigt
ich schaue jetzt nach Jobs als Putzfrau
tellerwäscherinnen oder
hotelreinigungskraft
ich würde ca 3000 Forint mehr verdienen
und nur acht Stunden pro Tag arbeiten
schon vor dem Krieg war das Staatsbudget
minus schon da begann die Inflation
Ungarns Abhängigkeit von Russland ist
groß die ungarische Raffinerie läuft nur
mit russischem Öl russland baut und
finanziert in Ungarn ein neues
Atomkraftwerk
und ein Sondervertrag garantiert Orban
billigere Gaspreise
bei eu-treffen bleibt Orban immer
häufiger allein auch weil er immer
wieder betont Sanktionen gegen Russland
seien sinnlos und der alleinige Grund
für die Inflation
wir haben eine sanktionsinflation wir
zahlen mehr für Energie wegen der
Sanktion wegen der nutzlosen
ineffektiven Sanktionen können wir die
hohen Energiepreise oder die Inflation
nicht ausgleichen wir müssen alle dafür
zahlen
er lässt das nun Plakatieren Brüssels
Sanktionen nicht Russlands Krieg sein
die Bombe und Marian wie alle Ungarn
bekommt eine sogenannte Konsultation ins
Haus die EU sei verantwortlich für
Missstände in Ungarn sie sei doch auch
gegen Sanktionen sie meint dass sei ein
durchsichtiges Manöver
das soll doch nur ablenken unter anderem
vom Bildungsproblem Problem das Geld
dafür hätte man doch besser für die
Bildung ausgeben können wir reden hier
über Milliarden forinto
[Applaus]
in Budapest wird nun immer häufiger
demonstriert
bei der großen Lehrer Demo ist doch
Marianne dabei es sind erstaunlich viele
denn die Regierung hat schon Lehrer
gefeuert anderen droht sie so mit
Entlassung wegen
illegalem Streit
aber es sind auch viele Schüler da das
ist neu das macht Marianne Mut
die Jugend kämpft um ihre Zukunft das
ist nicht mehr meine ich bin ja schon
alt es geht um ihre Zukunft
der Krieg verstärkt Probleme die es
längst schon gab
der Krieg polarisiert im Land und in
Europa
es wird ein heißer Winter auch in Ungarn
Orbans propotinposition wird auch für
die EU mehr und mehr zum Problem wie
sehr ist die Einheit in Europa gefährdet
dazu hat ulföller recherchiert und
dieses Video gemacht
und wie sehr sich weltweit gerade die
Macht verschiebt dazu hat MRT Wissen
recherchiert und dieses Video gemacht
und wenn ihr keine Folge von winter is
coming verpassen wollt dann abonniert
diesen Kanal